hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to comm time another game
from game jolt made by those lovely
people down there and if you've seen
seven days and I'm scared you'll
definitely like this one because it is
another pixelated style game now I don't
know a lot about this and I gotta be
frank with you we just finished
recording drunk minecraft still a little
tipsy but I want to play this because I
wanted to play this for a few days now
okay let's go into it oh I live in a
small cottage isolated from the town
silence is law such a place my home is
almost something akin to an inescapable
prison while the chirping of the
sparrows in the breath of the wind are
my sole company I like the sound of the
wind oh we all oh oh oh we're playing
okay sorry babe didn't know didn't I
just say that the chirping of the birds
and the wind of the wind was my only oh
my god what is wrong with your face
right now something you should say to a
little kid like this hello I didn't want
to come here I miss my mom why are you
here
why do you miss your mom am i holding
you prisoner in my inescapable prison
you don't like this place you know a kid
I don't blame you oh I can't go up they
were guests in my house they can't leave
them okay please taken sprint a bit
listen my bow beyal doesn't work here is
there something you can do about that
oh no Hello Baby how you owe my god do I
know the man in the suit jacket is
married this guy this disturbing looking
got here the guest should come soon
aren't they aren't you the guests you
all look very creepy by the way man this
party's such a bore when the other
guests are supposed to come well f you
man it's my party Oh dance if I want to
loo my best compliments for your home
it's truly beautiful well thank you
thank you very much I can't go down
there they're a guest at my okay
it yeah they're guests in my house but
they're awfully boring and mean hello
I'm happy to help with dinner or are you
baby you have no face at all you know to
be honest I shouldn't be here have you
seen the kid in some other room I'm
supposed to babysit him as soon as I
knew about this party I couldn't help
but come could you pass me that knife on
the table please
I'll cut the bread so we can serve it
all past it all right I'll pass it out
my no no my voice is very hoarse by the
way um okay I don't see anything there
are a lot of place settings here okay um
am I missing something
come on over here oh okay come on oh
there we go
yeah oh wait a minute wait a minute
could you pass me that knife on the
table please I'll get the breadstick is
there of it
wait a minute something right here oh my
god
oh oh no oh no you killed her
I oh my god you stabbed her you killed
her he'll be killed her he stabbed her
with a kitchen knife I'm very sorry I
didn't mean to press control to calm
yourself oh that just crouches me what
does that calm myself oh my guest rent
oh my god that is so morbid oh my god
well I guess finally I'm oh I need to go
to the under the basement to cut the
power
why but I guess that I am the crazed
bunch stabber finally oh oh oh my well I
guess I'm lucky that none of my guests
went down oh good are you okay you okay
lady I think she'll be fine
she'll be fine he'll be just fine good
god don't do that to me I'm not in a
disposition to handle that wait a minute
ah lady are you are you that lady
putting ghost shut up I don't have time
for this okay
hi I can't talk to you oh my god that
was incredibly loud I got a bad feeling
about this one
okay all right so all of my guests ran
outside I'm guessing that's where I need
to go and hunt them down and kill them
because that's normal behavior I need a
sprint or else is gonna take me forever
oh hi Oh get out of here where did he go
oh my god
he scared the bejesus out of me excuse
me oh my god I don't know I'm not I'm
not equipped right now to handle this
I was decreased but stabber and I saw
but I was gonna stab but apparently I
wasn't allowed to well okay was that
that blood did I actually oh what was
that noise
I'm not sure what then okay um okay I'm
a bit confused it was like randomly they
plucked some strings oh hi oh hi that
lady I don't like that lady she's not
real what what did he call me an effing
deviant what kind of [ __ ] are you as
if you're any better where'd you go
where did he go he ran off again good
god is someone hiding in here someone in
the closet maybe Oh No Oh where'd he go
he ran away
don't tell me you ran back inside that
would be very dumb of them what kind of
dinner guests come here to this gate
where they obviously can't get out of to
this house in the middle of the woods
just some weirdo who doesn't know anyone
but just randomly invited them out
and what kind of Gaul do I have as a
murderer to just kill everyone in
batches of like ten okay I don't know
where they went they like hiding corners
I don't they may have gone back inside
no no no I don't even know if they can
it's like I was sneaking up on them and
when they turned around and saw me that
ghosty goo girl came out and startled if
it's Jesus out of me
no they're not out here are they no they
must have gone back inside okay so that
means wait there's not a lot of room out
here to go I mean I've walked everywhere
right I'm assuming I'm just so I'm just
going on assumptions here jeez okay
so I cut the power which means that oh
oh I don't wanna kill the kid
don't wanna kill the kid whoa okay all
this so sad I'm not gonna kill him um
well I'm not gonna kill him first anyway
cuz I have a feeling the game wants me
to kill him
what is that this letter in oh no okay
sorry it's not that thing it look like a
white box head okay I'm gonna I don't
want to kill the kid that's so morbid
but I guess this game was like trying to
show wait what No okay this game is like
trying to show what it is to be the
murderer I'm guessing these are not
supposed to be easy choices here where
is everyone there's a lot of people here
but there's oh you don't say anything
you're looking at my prized goose oh no
no no no turn around
around man what are you looking at me
bro whoa whoa whoa you're quick for
being stabbed you're kind of quick ah
whoa you look messed up man oh hi lady
Oh God that is loud okay one down I
guess yes my precious goose please don't
worry
I will please you're on the road oh whoa
lady you need to stop that oh hello baby
it's so more no no no don't no you don't
see anything you don't see anything
she's like what was that hmm
still smoking my nice that nice no come
back here lady why are you so
disturbingly creepy oh okay I think that
lady is trying to stop me from killing
people oh man okay okay all right then
that's oh hey you're there good god stop
that maybe I'm supposed to stab the lady
in white of lunch maybe I don't have to
kill everyone if I oh that's still very
loud thank you what do you do it is
still quite loud she just goes back and
forth am I supposed to stab her how I
asked to turn my volume down but I like
to keep it up you know and I don't think
that's doing me anything
I'm gonna try to find the rest of all my
guests I don't know where they went they
kind of vanished on me he just
disappeared
I mean I looked outside but I don't know
where they went
okay whoa well I'm crouching there we go
okay so oh you you insulted my hose I
don't run away from me
damn you're quick would you go please
don't tell me you went outside again
no I'm guessing they wouldn't want to
hide where the dead bodies are that's
just a hunch
is it just me or can I not see as far as
I used to damn it where the hell are
these guys they're nowhere to be found
Oh
oh come back here come back here man
oh you went upstairs a what upstairs a
we're hiding with the kid there ready go
oh he went up here I know he did he go
come on damn it
nope damn it where did he go these
[ __ ] are oh that's the lady oh oh
wait what what there's a blood trail oh
my that's really cool do not take kindly
to that you're being very I still don't
know who that lady is is that lady the
same lady that's downstairs I really
don't know but she's awfully just this
game is just disturbing on multiple
level I don't even want to be the crazy
blood stabber I really don't I think I
saw I don't wanna
oh no oh no oh I feel so bad but
remember guys this is just a game oh
that's awful
Jesus stop that lady oh I guess this is
the point of the game to make you feel
guilt for what you do but man oh man
this is so morbid oh this is so wrong
but I guess that's the point in the game
to make you feel I think that I think
the kid ran outside or the douche I'd
rather kill anyone I know you guys say
that oh this game oh I wasn't ready to
go in I was I was just came home from
know it's morbid stab kill people time I
guess so awful who is left anyway is it
just the guy left is that like a clue
telling me where people are cuz I heard
that in my right ear is that over here
no maybe no damn it
where did this guy go I didn't check the
basement I didn't check the basement
again someone might have run down there
yes no I didn't check the basement now
as soon as I cut the power
I only played the place I saw someone
was over here wasn't it over here right
no yes No maybe so no no no no no no
damn he must have ran to the basement
he must've because I don't see him here
I think it's just the last guy left the
spiky eared guy can't believe I'm I
can't believe I'm actual God lady you
are creepy as hell so please go away oh
there you are
[Music]
I feel uncomfortable I mean in certain
games there are games that force you to
do really creepy and disturbing things
but I mean it's weird that's such a
pixelated game kids make me feel like
that that's really well done I will
amaze very well done
it's very morbid but it is well done yes
I can't help think that this is a very
well made game it is incredibly well
made I mean in just the design aspect
obviously it's not graphically great
office it's not game style great it is
just the concept he's rock solid and
100% weird and a hundred percent free me
and I disturbed and I guess that's the
point so anyway that's all for this good
god thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always
see you in the next
[Music]
No
we're
the doors to that way
my still running or what mister running
what still running my still running is
this me running
like